il
[Musique]
m
bonjour à toutes et à tous soyez les
bienvenus vous regardez quatre premières
non magazine consacré au tour de la
martinique des yoles rondes wi'am ça me
fait voilà mon bien ravis d'accueillir
une nouvelle fois au marxisme désirent
parfaire j'ai pendant toute la semaine
ensemble tous les jours on sera au coeur
de l'ambiance est au coeur de la course
car le tour de la martinique des yoles
rondes c'est l'événement sportif le plus
festif et le plus fédérateur de vie le
faire c'est la 34ème édition 16
équipages ont pris le départ lui tu
étape palpitante nous attendent
la question que tout le monde se pose
est ce que rosette/orange tenant du
titre va réaliser un doublé et bien pas
si sûr car la yole se pratiquer toute
l'année et c'est ufr chanflor qui a
remporté le championnat ils sont partis
ce matin de chaque chaire pour arriver
ici sur la plage du fraîcheur que c'est
une pâte et en mer pour cette première
étape dans ses coups cela des collisions
des yoles qui prennent l'eau d'autres
qui coule des verbes folle d'esprit tous
les ingrédients réunis pour faire de
cette entame de tours 2018 une course à
suspense à départ donné à schoelcher pas
de prologue cette année les 16
embarcations doivent longe la côte
caraïbe vers le nord et rallier la ligne
d'arrivée au prêcheur après avoir des
seynois à bâbord on à saint-pierre le
départ gros cafouillage entre plusieurs
embarcations
sanction immédiate pour ce même monsieur
bricolage et 10-40 les trois
embarcations coulées doivent regagner la
plage pour remater sous les
encouragements du public devant cette
aide et mdf prend la tête de la course
ambitieux
les hommes de mario malterie entend
marquer une voile plus grande que vos
coupes leurs adversaires mais attention
aux variations de conditions climatiques
sur le parcours
à défaut de sponsors a kiffé rohner
laguiole de sainte anne se contentent de
bien porté son nom
à eelv on est dans le trio de tête
je
derrière visite à tête en grande
difficulté la berd a quitté l'encoche du
bas de longues minutes les équipiers
vont tenter l'impossible avant de
finalement abdiqué
en tête de course le choix de voiles de
ces tdm sang bleu payant mais
l'embarcation toujours en tête se fait
attaquer par une affaire chance lors
emmené par un félix mérine en quête de
dixième victoire au tour la voile noir
résiste tant bien que mal
[Musique]
la de viol de tête distance
rosette/orange ait d'ouvragé afin
caraïbes et zapetti l'appaloosa à bord
du dernier jugement les frères masse
cherche le bon réglage il se verrait
bien rééditer la performance de 2016
l'équipage est serein sûr car à kandy la
stratégie se mette en branle la gueule
change d'équipier prend l'avantagé sur
ces tdm plaisir de courte durée au jeu
des virements de bord nouveau changement
de position une guerre assassines qui
permet le retour de jets l'afa caraïbes
et rosette orange mais surtout qui
pousse les hommes de 7 et des âmes à la
faute
mario matt grippe a sans doute ici un
choix de voiles trop ambitieux et cool
à la grande satisfaction des roberts
derrière l'armé fatale va quant à elle
se ferme une belle frayeur mais à cauet
c'est coursier vont in extremis à
réussir à maintenir leur yole hors de
l'eau plus de peur que de mal également
plongé afin hainaut sur bricolage qui
rentrent en collision
persuadé d'occuper la tête de course
félix mérine et son équipage agite la
bague est active des bassines mais le
passage de la bouée au large de saint
pierre signe le retour dans la course
des yoles à rester plus à terre se marre
est petit navire est en tête devant l
douvan zapetti l'appaloosa et ufr sont à
la lutte mais c'est bien ufr qui va
prendre l'avantagé à les taquiner la
yole de tête
la voile blanche se fait de plus en plus
menaçantes dans le sillage de chaabi nan
jusqu à n'en faire qu'une bouchée
l'équipage du affaire début de ce tour
2018 avec une première victoire
déferlement de blanc sur la plage de
l'arrivée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
belle entame de tout repos ufr chanflor
qui s'offre donc une première victoire
devant se marrer petit navire à une
minute 54 secondes
les appétits l'appaloosa troisième à 5
minutes trente et une secondes
brasserie lorraine sarah énergies
nouvelles est quatrième après son avarie
rosette orange caraïbe limite la casse
et fini cinquième à tout vent et
finalement 6e c'était derrière edf
10e contre-performance de gf à karaj qui
franchit 11e la ligne d'arrivée après
avoir coulé royal fruit de martinique
adeptes et 12e semaine dernier n'est
jamais parvenu à revenir dans la course
laguiole accuse déjà un retard d'une
heure 13 minutes et 52 secondes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
oh
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hu
félix mérine super faut savoir naviguer
il faut savoir à quel moment changer le
vent ce sont des hommes soleil ils
connaissent la mer connaissent chacun
connaît son métier
voilà à quel moment lâché le bâlois n'a
pas viré du sport cbas super c'est que
les contrôles parce que je suis un père
david pratiques et gestes j'allais
toujours autour des hold vous êtes
contente
l'amour est faible je suis joueur
[Musique]
ces projets permettent un marché où l'on
voulons
vous avez une yole préféré à ste rose
est alors vous êtes ils en sont où la
haye sont loin ouais chaîne pas
exactement la prochaine étape rosette
on t'attend je le vois quelqu'un
je suis en finale b c'est bien mais il
faut succomber stone avec ce aussi parce
que ce travail de longue haleine
donc il faut que les autres accès à moi
je suis en fait deux péchés comme on
perd là la pêche y avait pas qu'on les
moteurs dont qu'ils allaient à la voile
donc je sais que c'est un boulot
difficile donc il faut applaudir tout le
monde même si c'est le dernier qui
arrive il faut qu'on reste là pour les
accueillir
donc beaucoup âge a eu à faire pour la
prochaine fois mais comme tous pour moi
tous ces organes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouah ouah
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les avec vos pages qui sont engagés sur
ce tour de la martinique des yoles
rondes ont travaillé très dur pendant
toute l'année pour être au top
aujourd'hui pour le départ de cette 34e
édition
qu'est-ce qui a fait la différence
aujourd'hui quels ont été les bons choix
de voix les bons choix tactiques sur
l'eau les réponses avec les patrons eux
mêmes c'est pas aux almadies
[Musique]
c'est tenté tôt le matin on a perdu il
ya dix ans ils ont fait des bonds
judicieux c'est très bien et après comme
le vent aussi on n'a plus besoin de nos
voiles et non il ya des vues que c'est
pour tout le monde c'était très
difficile
on a repris la tête j'ai dit c'est
dommage guy albert parce que je vois il
n'a pas il n'a pas beaucoup d'équipages
ils étaient allaités en tête
ça fait trois ans qu'on n'a pas gagné
quand même ça fait quand même pour une
équipe comme nous ça fait ça fait long
c'était une étape très très très
difficile même nous nous sommes assez
bien au delà du volet là et on a su
porter notre voix ici malheureusement
l'année mais bon c'est pas tout à fait
arrivée à saint pierre on a choisi
l'option d'autre que de limiter la casse
on n'a pas pris le relais avec lui ça
sert à rien parce que je sais que tu
peux abandonner dix minutes quand même
pas arrivés au coucher au donc on a fait
un choix de rester ou soulager les gars
parce que le tour est long c'était une
étape très difficile mais comme j'ai
annoncé avant sera plus difficile que
les autres mais nous sommes en attaque
un soupir et les mad house et rouge la
police fait que geste était au départ un
dock on savait qu'il y aurait un
carambolage donc on n'a pas su en nature
et c'est la surestimation bon après
les yoles les communes fr les appétits
bon ils ont une vision pris une bonne
option
après on savait que 314 sans les payer
puisque on sait qu'il ya beaucoup de
monde il ya énormément de courses est
jeune donc arriver au carbet d'autopsié
pays et ça nous avait mis d'entrée
améliorer ce matin on était parti pour
gagner jusqu'à saint pierre on était
premiers un manque de vigilance et là on
a pris de l'eau sont là en assombri ce
qui nous a coûté la première place et
puis on a pris on a perdu du temps par
rapport aux autres favoris mais bon
c'est la première journée dans
l'ensemble ça a été une bonne journée il
fallait faire les diables rouges il
fallait se remettre en question je pense
dès demain on verra lier leurs roses et
oranges à l'avant parce que je pense que
nos supporters et nous mêmes on a envie
de lui faire plaisir mais aussi on a
envie de faire le doublé c'est à dire
l'an dernier on a gagné cette année on
va tout essayer pour ça et voilà
[Musique]
plutôt mal sellette sa williams
qu'est-ce que je suis bien et si ça fait
quoi neuf ans que je viens
merci infiniment de m'inviter pour le
tour des yoles a présenté avec toi ta
première je sais que désormais je me
sens un petit peu d'âme à la maison mais
tigana la maison tu es chez toi je suis
ravi d'accueillir je sais qu'il ya des
changements sur le tour cette année oui
jérôme bizart mais en fait on va pas
faire le tour de l'île
toutes les étapes de se dérouler sur la
côte caraïbe alors william qu'ils ont
les meilleures personnes composant
talent mais coûte ce sont les supporters
on leur a posé la question c'est notre
séquence samba faye du jour ya quand
même des choses qui ne changent pas et
si google toujours aussi un
rafraîchisseur tour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cya on pense que la plus intéressante
bon mon côte caraïbe
c'est pas aussi facile gros le coin
[Musique]
mais c'est bien vous sont à
décentraliser le tour cette année
pourquoi les problèmes de santé has
c'est tout à fait normal
on essaie de changer le système pas mais
je suis d'accord je ne suis pas autant
la corde je suis là comme ça l'année
prochaine comme un délit c'est important
que le trou va décider où les loups a
beaucoup de suspense et moi du moment
qu'ils allaient tous c'est le principal
des yodleurs qui ont l'habitude les
mapipi comme on dit mais normalement
sont friands de du tout mais dans
l'autre sens tandisque là c'est un peu
particulier donc elles seront surtout ya
des ailes qui seront dans leurs formules
ce sera l'occasion pour elle de montrer
qu'un ça fait quelque chose et je suis
persuadé qu'il faut que je pense que les
cartes sont peut-être au disque dieu
parce qu'il ya des des petits équipage
entre guillemets qui n'ont pas forcément
l'occasion de s'exprimer sur des grosses
étapes comme ça peut-être que là ce sera
peut-être l'occasion de se démarquer un
petit peu mais en soit on fait avec moi
à faire avec
[Musique]
dommage ce qu'il y avait de belles de
blg table et
bon ça lui fait de plus en plus le nom
et c'est pas mal je suspens les cieux
prier sans labour et on perd beaucoup ce
n'est pas la nationale sur ce moment
avec les sages on n'a pas le choix
vous savez nous tous à la table du
diable tout sans passer par là
olivier bon moi c'est un fait
on verra c'est pas satisfaisant
personnellement je ne suis pas à ma
triste mais je suis là et je trouve
dommage que ça fasse que du lourd on n'a
pas beaucoup de deux parties dans le sud
avec les sags est ça gâche tout le temps
il ya toujours de l'intérêt puisque sur
cette zone caraïbes il peut y avoir
toutes sortes de choses on a plus de
zerg est en tête ou qui ont coulé il ya
eu des choix de
des choix stratégiques différents donc
il doit toujours un intérêt c'est vrai
qu'on a toujours regretté de ne pas
avoir la haute mer sur huit jours d'un
coup si on ne peut avoir que des
surprises que de la fatigue il faut être
vigilant du début à la fin il ya qu à
voir aujourd'hui
comment les écarts entre les premiers
viols s'était retiré tous ses procès à
l'abri de saint pierre ce sera comme ça
presque à tous les jours mais bon faut
savoir que demain ils ont encore plus
d'air et à l'apl qui va arriver ils ont
encore beaucoup de chevaux puissent tous
ceux qui ne connaissent pas cette côte
ya un petit problème libyen avant une
chute
donc voilà il y aura moi j'ai beau tout
le monde
[Musique]
laguiole et un bateau à voile
traditionnellement utilisés par les
pêcheurs qui n'existe qu'ici en
martinique
c'est donc notre patrimoine depuis 34
ans cette activité est devenue un sport
à part entière la grâce au tour de la
martinique des yoles rondes
grande nouveauté cette année dans quatre
premières nous allons décrypter
techniquement un élément de laguiole
chaque jour on commence avec le mât le
poteau mitan de laguiole alors milian
qu'est ce que ça veut dire potomitan
potomitan en fait en créole ça veut dire
pilier on dit souvent que les mamans
sont les poto mitan des familles en
martyr et donc on commence avec le mât
le mât qui tient la voix la voile qui
est le moteur de la yole c'est à cliquer
[Musique]
le main est un arbrisseau de bois cote
d'autres essences ou en assemblage vos
couverts de fibre de verre ou de carbone
le mas et le phoma mesure de 7 à 11
mètres en fonction de la taille de la
voile il pèse près de 80 qui à l'origine
le my le phoma était en bois brut des
essences solide
lourdes est imputrescible été utilisés
[Musique]
sur ces images de 1992 des coursiers
prélève des arbrisseaux en forêt sur les
yeux du patron georges henri lagier des
maçons et literie
[Musique]
de nos jours le mât et parfois le
résultat d'un assemblage à la base il y
a encore du bois côté au sommet du pain
plus les jeux le tout consolidé avec de
la fibre de verre ou de carbone
le mât est renforcée par un faux m'a
placé devant lui sur la yole la durée de
vie du mas varie de 1 à 5 ans selon la
qualité de fabrication l'entretien et le
nombre d'utilisations le banc en bois
brut démarre à 400 euros mais cela peut
aller jusqu'à 6000 euros pour des
marbres à importer vos couverts de
carbone sa fonction fixée la voix le
mile au chômage sont placés dans des
trous appeler d'autres
thibault est stabilisé avec des cales en
bois ils sont attachés entre eux avec
des semble le phoma renforce le mât et
permet de le maintenir droit pour bien
tenir la voile même en cas de grosses
rafales
depuis 2010 est les maquereaux sont
autorisés ils sont très rigides et du
léger mais certains kaupthing ils voient
une atteinte à la tradition
alors qui
croix rouge est
- sur la route que la meilleure gagne
pareil que le meilleur gagne il faudrait
quand même choisir sa yole en péril au
tour a commencé pour l'instant je ne
sais pas encore ce que je vais soutenir
et william moi je supporte personne mais
toi tu devrais faire ton soit le tour
est lancée c'est maintenant qu'il faut
choisir d'ailleurs l'analyse de notre
spécialiste va peut être aider à faire
ton choix
jean trudeau va décrypter la course du
jour et nous dire ce qui peut faire la
différence demain aujourd'hui pour
première étape on ne savait pas vraiment
ce qu'il fallait faire comme choix le
voit maintenant le parcours a été très
technique et très tactique
soit on reste à la côte on va chercher
le vent les bonnes rafales soit en sort
à l'extérieur
les deux options en payer parce que les
yoles qui ont terminé devant ont pris
chacune à leur tour des options qui ont
fait qu'elle se sont retrouvés sur la
ligne d'arrivée au prêcheur avec eux
tous quelque soit ordinaire le premier
ancien vainqueur du tour félix mérine
choi fm selon le deuxième ancien
vainqueur du tour guy albert romer sous
sommes avec petit naviaux le troisième
loïc masse sur l'appétit l'appaloosa
demain on est dans le même plan d'eau
n'est pas le même parcours et pas les
mêmes conditions de vent donc ça veut
dire que ça va gamberger dans la tête y
compris ceux qui sont derrière qui avait
prétendu gagner chaque étape du tour ça
ne s'est pas fait ça va se faire
remettre demain il y aura une très très
belle course d'autant que le roi vient
pas au prêcheur
après tout le circuit à aller à ses
pieds au carbet on va virer les la perle
avec toutes les difficultés que l'on
connaît pour arriver aux pêcheurs
bingo
la vraie vie
[Musique]
au canada chalsa
première étape du tour évidemment rien
n'est joué
on l'a bien vu à l'arrivée il y avait
très peu d'écart entre les équipages
deuxième étape palpitante nous attend
demain le départ et l'arrivée se
dérouleront ici sur la plage du prêcheur
les détails du profil de l'étape d'un
cap la deuxième est un pécheur pécheur
départ à 10 heures sur la plage du bourg
du prêcheur longer la côte en exploitant
ces petites rafales de vent qui viennent
de la rivière sèche puis ces grosses
rafales qui descendent de la montagne
pelée la marque numéro un à saint pierre
direction sète manque au numéro 2 qui se
situe au carbet puis un long ou autour
des îles et la paire on va traverser la
bête ces pierres on va sortir de ces
rafales voile filets toujours si le vent
et s nord d'ace pour tenter de se
rapprocher de la côte de ne pas rester
trop large de manière à pouvoir aller
vers cette île et l'appel que nous
devrons laisser à tribord l'île et la
perle se situe au large de lens
couleuvres tout le monde connaît bien
ensuite on laisse cette marque qui est
une marque de parcours on la laisse sur
tribord et on revient toujours le long
de la côte soit en tirant des bords soit
un goût 10 ans ou une arrivée en soit
les deux bouts et devant la plage du
bourg du pêcheur
[Musique]
washington 10 mars et la fin de première
année des maturités yolande on est parti
pour vivre ensemble semaine de fruits
on vous donne rendez vous demain ici
même fraîcheur pour une belle régate
dans la baie il y aura toujours autant
d'ambiance et les conseillers plus rond
au bout d'eux-mêmes retrouver qu'à
première à grains peur que les joueurs
sur martinique 1ère et à 7h35 sur france
ô à demain nos coeurs et nos mains de
cacahouète demain ça fait neuf ans que
tu es en martinique tu connais le créole
maintenant au maine où k way demain je
n'avais jamais entendu tu m'as pas
données d'accès cours de vente
[Musique]